So we recorded Lecture one last
night, and we're just
rehearsing Lecture three,
I think, at the moment.
So it's surrounded by
the paraphernalia of
the Lectures to come.
But I just wanted to take a
moment to tell you about the
Ames room behind me, which
was one of the
demos from last night.
I don't think we actually
mentioned it was
called an Ames room.
It's named after Adelbert Ames,
which is a great name,
who was an ophthalmologist. I
don't know what he was doing
inventing distorted perspective
rooms like this
but he did.
So quite early on, we decided
we wanted to build one of
these on this scale.
I was hoping, Andy, you might
be able to make an
Ames room for us.
Yeah, I like that comment.
Did you notice that -
Oh, I didn't see
that actually.
No, that'd be really good fun.
It has to be fairly large.
Yeah.
Choose two kids who are the
same height, and you can
measure them up and then be sure
and then they walk into
it, and they walk backwards
and forwards, and you
literally see them growing.
And it's extraordinary.
We started looking on
the net for plans of
how we might do this.
Downloaded a couple which seemed
not particularly good,
so we thought we'd do all the
calculations ourselves and
work out exactly how to go
about building this.
So that manifested itself
in fairly complicated
spreadsheets, which gave
rise to prototype
one, which is here.
I don't think you can really see
into it through that hole.
But you look through that
hole, and you see...
If I look through, I can
just about see a room.
So this gave me the confidence
that we could make something
roughly right.
So the next stage was to build
a slightly more serious scale
model of what we wanted
to build.
Roughly a one-tenths
scale of the main.
Once we'd made this, I was
pretty confident that we could
make the real thing and
make it look good.
I hadn't anticipated some of the
woodwork challenges that
were to come.
So this took about three or
four days work to build.
And when I say days, I'm talking
24 hours, basically.
It's almost nonstop
work on this.
There were three of us,
me and Mellis and
Gaz making this room.
Some of the beams at the far
end, there's some really weird
double compound cuts going on.
So it's pretty complicated
stuff.
And one of those days was just
decorating it, and finding
some nice pictures from the
collection, which is quite a
nice touch, I think.
We probably finished off the
floor about 45 minutes before
the start of the show
last night.
So it was typical last-minute
stuff.
It was really great to see it
work as well as it did on
camera last night.
It was really fantastic.
If you did ever wonder what on
earth you learned trigonometry
for, this is it right here.